Wait, Kronos is gone? Don't Don't be passive-aggressive. Don't
be passive-aggressive. Don't be passive-aggressive. Don't be
passive Come on, man. Don't do it. He is the guy everybody thought
he was and he's learned nothing.
This Quintia, we've got pirate software start content. It's been
a while. I'm here for it. I'm here for it. We got Well, maybe
Twitch's second biggest roach, we should say. As mentioned watching
a video that was criticizing you for mentioning you work at Blizzard
so much. I literally never talk about it. When I worked at Blizzard,
I did that for Blizzard. Blizzard Blizzard Blizzard Blizzard
7 years, yeah. Blizzard Blizzard I used to work at Blizzard Entertainment.
I used to work at Blizzard Entertainment. Used to work at Blizzard
Entertainment. You're red team specialist for Blizzard Entertainment
and Blizzard Blizzard Blizzard Blizzard is having worked at Blizzard
Blizzard Blizzard Blizzard. I grew up at Blizzard. Blizzard Blizzard
Blizzard Blizzard industry for Blizzard Entertainment. Blizzard
Blizzard Blizzard Blizzard. It's about the zero accountability
is what makes us so mad. There's no zero accountability, dude.
Everyone can do something better. But when you when you open
up and you yell over another person
>> Nah, I'm good. You See you.
I'm not doing that [__] again with him. Nah. He did
it the first time. I'm not doing it a second one. Pirate software
is having the worst meltdown of his career and is losing hundreds
of thousands of followers. >> This loved YouTuber lost
230,000
subscribers in 1 month. >> I'm here for it. We got Well,
maybe Twitch's second biggest roach, we should say. Let's go
Well, depending on how racist you are, maybe you argue third,
but second for sure. >> that I am making this video right
now. And no, um it's not because it's a pirate video. I'm not
going for the sarcasm route here. Uh pirate software's crew,
more specifically his first mate, that being Kronos, his head
moderator, and the rest of his mod >> Wait. Wait, Kronos
is gone? Oh my god. If you guys don't know who Kronos is, Kronos
has like done so much work, like fake fake reports all over the
place, fake DMCAs for pirate software to get clips down from
LiveStreamFails.
This Kronos guy was his ride or die. If Kronos is gone, things
are truly
done in the pirate software sphere,
Uh his viewership's pretty good. It's holding. I mean, it's not
as good as it was, but it's holding. Dude, it's really bad though
if you go back like
the here. Oh my goodness. You go back a little further. Oh yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's kind of rough, man. Realistically, the clavicular formula
was proven out originally by pirate software, wasn't it? Like
when you think about it, it's pirate software who proved that
formula out. That like you don't actually have to be smart or
funny or entertaining or anything. Literally just getting in
front of enough eyes, you will grow massively.
That whole clipping formula, getting my short Get your shorts
out everywhere, getting your face everywhere.
I'm just saying you got to You get people in and
you build up massively.
Anyway, so now we're down to 2,000. But I mean, that's still
respectable. You can still do stuff with like 2,000 average viewers.
I can't believe the Kronos guy is gone. I thought the Kronos
guy would be there forever.
>> Have you ever been fired or jumped ship? And in doing
a bit of research, there has been some very interesting details
that have come out surrounding this mass exodus  firing
that has just gone down. Like Pirate apparently calling Kronos
a parasite as well as the rest of the moderation team seemingly
starting to jump onto the What?  firing that has just
gone down. Like Pirate apparently calling Kronos a parasite uh
Kronos is the guy who also was like I think Kronos was the guy
who was organizing people buying subs for pirate software to
keep his streamathon going. Right? His like his huge hype train
that he had, like he set the hype train record. I think Kronos
was the guy and I think Kronos was even putting his own money
into it.
Like Kronos built this guy up. Massively. as well as the rest
of the moderation team seemingly starting to jump onto the pirate
software hate train. We had some sleeper cells from Quaker Nation
infiltrate the very public uh Discord that Kronos has himself,
where he hopped into a voice call alongside a lot of the other
mods who seem to just be chatting. And it seems that they were
having some conversations in regard to their tenure working for
pirate software, and I would say the negative aspects of that,
which are going to become very apparent. And I thought to myself,
well, given the severity of of what is going down here with a
lot of the pirate software community, you know, leaving the community
leaders. Well, I guess to me it just feels like the pirate software
ship is finally sinking. This may come as a bit of a shock because
Kronos was interacting during that time and communicating with
the different parties, including I'm Fetus. Now, this got brought
to my attention through uh my Discord as we have a couple of
threads for, you know, drama discussion. Speaking of, hey, check
pinned comment. Might be a Discord link if you're 18 and up,
like play video games, chat drama. But you can see here it says,
"No longer engaged on pirate software work or associated with
him. Contact him directly or go to his Discord server." Now,
that is not worded a very positive way. But of course, that could
just be how I'm perceiving this. Let's just kind of go into more
of the details. Now, just one more tiny prerequisite, the only
person that I'm going to be like showing their Discord name and
stuff is going to be Kronos. But for the sake of just like keeping
it nice and simple, I am going to have blacked out all the other
names. Now, I have reached out to two other separate mods to
see if they were willing to comment. I'll also include screenshots
of those. They were not interested in having a conversation.
I don't necessarily blame them, but wanted to show you guys that
I made some sort of effort to reach out to them. After those
two responses, I figured, "Okay, I think I know how they're all
going to be." And I even shot a whisper to Kronos, but of course,
he did not reply and he's got me blocked on every other platform.
So, this is kind of like the first evidence to [laughter] show
you guys to show what I'm talking about here. This is uh Kronos
the Kronos zone. Oh god.
Dude, this is why this is honest to god why I just dropped even
trying to include Discord in my community in almost any way is
I just felt like I felt like basically
everybody who uses Discord is so conflict-avoidant
that they will all go and like talk about stuff in another place
and either never inform you that something was wrong or just
like inform you that they're all done with you cuz something
was wrong. And I'm just like, "Okay."
People who use Discord like a lot, it's just Dude, it's There's
just nothing you can do, man. Great. >> Kronos in a VC
call as screenshotted here with a few other mods, as well as
I think a few ex-members of Pirate's Discord. And there's a bit
of chatting here, you know, it just kind of seems like, you know,
Kronos is speaking out loud and the rest of them are pretty much
just like uh you know, chatting by typing in the VC chat. Now,
again, I don't have concrete proof that they're always talking
about Pirate, but using context clues, I think it's easy to kind
of uh understand sometimes when they're for sure probably talking
about him. In this case here, right behind me, somebody here
says, "Just anything that might be used against him or prove
him wrong gets nuked." The Now, from what I understand, most
of these messages come from around the same VC over the course
of a couple hours in that evening. And I'll just be reading through
the main points, but feel free to pause and and read the additional
stuff at at your own pace, whatever. But the top This is all
good. This is all funny for me that all of these people are going
to leave pirate software's community. I'm mostly looking for
where we'll get Oh, this part. Okay. So, what is this nuke that
that I've missed apparently? It sounds mad. Blank, it's the principle.
It's not It's not stud down to his level. Dude, what the [__]
are these people How do these people type? I did put the stick
to the hornet's nest for a bit of the community 2 days ago, so
What was the nuke? Thor accused Kronos of being a parasite and
removed his mod access to Discord, Twitch, etc.
Bro, that's That's crazy. >> So, what is this nuke that's
dropped that I've apparently missed? It sounds mad. And someone
replied to them down here, "Thor accused Kronos of being a parasite
and removed his mod access to Discord  Twitch
etc." That is where I'm getting this, you know, he was called
a parasite thing, and it seems like shortly after that he ends
up putting in his two weeks. I say that because in this other
screenshot here, we can see uh this, "Going to prepare the
stress." They also follow up and now this kind of seems to get
into them, you know, airing their grievances with Pirate saying,
"Comment all the collab and raids you did to all different people
versus Thor on a loop only raiding the ferrets does say a lot."
Seemingly talking about him being selfish. Another previous mod
saying, "Just waiting for PS stream and general chat to realize
it." I'm assuming
This is This is talking about Okay, some One of the mods was
like collabing, doing raids with other people, and Thor literally
keeps all the viewers for himself, is trying to insulate himself
from his own community. >> realized that all of the mods
have disappeared. Someone else saying, "Same here for Block Game."
I actually have a really funny clip in regard to that. Not exactly
the same, but very similar. Now, Block Game was this like Minecraft
thing that Pirate Software was working on with one of the mods
here as like the lead kind of uh Java developer for it, which
they ended up stepping which they ended up stepping down because
Pirate wanted it all to be converted over to Hytale, which was
a huge job to do, and the mod was like, "I'm not capable of doing
this at this time." But Block Game wasn't receiving updates,
and apparently it had been down for 4 days, and nobody noticed
until uh Thor got a Texas speech in his stream chat literally
today or yesterday as the time that you're watching this. And
here's that clip. Block Game is down. It's been down for like
4 days, and no one said a word. I'll go put it back up. He's
going to He's going to get so tilted by that cuz he's going to
be like, "This is a thing and none of you guys care." and Oh
boy.
He'd be so tilted. >> to see how long it would like Don't
Don't Don't be passive-aggressive. Don't be passive-aggressive.
Don't be passive-aggressive. Don't be passive Come on, man. Don't
do it. Don't do it to your chat.
Oh, I was going to see if anybody noticed. I just wanted to see
how long it would take for anybody to notice that our thing's
down. Nobody really cares about the community
And I don't even know why I'm doing this. Nobody cares about
the ferrets.
Nobody cares about me.
Nobody cares about Pirate Software. I was trying to see how long
it would like I feel it it would take you for somebody to actually
check. But nobody seemed to
Oh, you can hear that resentment building. Holy but nobody seemed
to care. Now the following screenshots are not in any particular
order maybe just because I think that's going to be a viewing
experience I know I Insane behavior,
Insane behavior, dude. I knew I had a Pirate Software soundboard
on here. Let's go. Truly this is just kind of a highlight reel
of You guys if you guys are new like if I know a lot of Twitch
chatters are new but when the Pirate Software with the Warcraft
drama dropped I was all over that covering the drama stuff cuz
that's like a lot of the content I was doing back then. I I still
will do a lot of drama stuff but man I was on the Pirate Software.
I love that stuff. It was so good. It was so so good.
Yeah, it was so good man. And I was covering it so my my chat
was getting mad. Same way I they did with Hutch. Okay, I was
just 6 hours of Pirate Software every stream. Except actually
people weren't even really getting mad cuz everyone loves sharking
Pirate Software. All right, this guy deserved every ounce of
hate he got. He was like the most hateable person and he just
kept upping the ante and now he's like kind of falling off but
I feel I'm feeling amp just watching this. I like just watching
him be a be a totally narcissistic prick to everybody after he's
down 10x viewers.
Yeah, he just that's he is the guy everybody thought he was and
he's learned nothing. of some of the stuff that they were saying.
This one right here people are saying hi to each other and then
I think they're again talking directly to Chronos here while
he's in call. I think you were a shield for a lot of BS. And
then a bunch of people saying I cancelled mine from renewing
mine will expire soon will end in June. I believe they're talking
about subscriptions to Pirate. Following up in this one it's
kind of clear that the other moderators really were not a fan
of Pirate Software probably not even Chronos himself towards
the end. Someone said here there's a reason why I wanted this
community be good for you and for all the mods to be chill and
be safe from him. Someone said well you did lure in people with
someone's name. You're warmer person. He in the community were
begging you to stream. And then someone else saying you were
the reason why he didn't lose mods and other streamers quicker.
Now this could be Chronos it could be also they were chatting
up It's it is so insanely redacted. >> amongst each other
a different mod in this chat here. But still like making a a
point like you're the reason why he didn't lose mods and other
streamers quicker is is crazy. And I do want to jump in and just
make it clear I'm not doing this to be like aha I told you so
or anything. I'm actually really surprised that the full mod
team has dropped. I it really Bro, you got merch dancing on this
guy's grave. Why are you pretending that you're not doing this
to say haha ha I told you so. Why even come on. Come on.
Come on, man. Seemed like these people were Rider Dies and from
my understanding with as long as they had lasted alongside him
I thought that maybe Pirate had been treating them better than
how he treats his community at times versus how he treats people
that are more you know public facing like the dramas that we've
talked about but that is just simply not the case. As a matter
of fact one of them pointed out that one of the reasons that
they stopped watching him was how mean he was being to his viewers.
There's just some kind of like chatting between them and then
right at the bottom here my biggest problem with him and why
I stopped watching him was the casual cruelty he showed to members
of the community. And so again this wasn't just reserved for
you know just random members of the community it was clear that
it was also him treating his mod team like this including Chronos
like calling him a parasite and all this after you know pretty
much everyone has dipped on Pirate. Most of his fan base most
of the viewers that he would have had
Calling calling out Chronos is crazy. Wasn't Pirate's big thing
that he paid his mods and got them benefits and That was his
big thing and but I don't know man I don't think you do that
on a 2000 viewer stream.
So he had like a huge community going and he was making a bunch
of money. I don't know how he's managing that to be honest with
you like everything falling down like this. I don't I wonder
how he's managing it cuz it seemed like he actually incurred
a lot of cost to build this community in the first place.
And I don't know
Yeah, I I don't know. He did up and his mods helped him do it.
Man, you need somebody who could be like a touchstone if you're
going to be a content creator cuz sometimes it's important to
like take a stand on But Pirate Software took every bad stand
every incorrect stand to take Pirate Software took it all the
way along, right? He just couldn't act like a human being. He
had way too he had a massive ego. He couldn't see himself as
incorrect in any situation.
He just doubled down on every dumb thing he said. Dude, I I don't
know how you even operate as a streamer. I don't know how he
got that big in the first place. Like it feels like he should
have made
to fix himself over way before he way before he got that big.
are completely gone and now it seems like he is also just turning
on everyone that's close to him. Or maybe this has been a very
slow burn over the course of the last couple of years and now
it's finally culminating because he probably can't pay them.
Or at the very least he can't pay most of the mod team that he
originally had when he was talking about you know paying for
their dental and having them have insurance and full paid you
know full time jobs. Another interaction here someone says hm
toxic ex could be referencing you know what's being chatted about.
Someone says or he does some BS to community when you had mental
health day like AP stuff in December. Basically [__]
with your days off. Now this could just be them you know like
oh yeah and then when when [__] hit the fan like
when you had to be out something was going on. It sounded like
he was pointing out the fact that there were a few you know Pirate
fans that were also you know being a little too intense thinking
that you know Fetus was directly targeting Pirate in some malicious
way when he was doing the parody I'm truly just speculating there
I have nothing to back it but that's you know the best thing
that I could come up with. It realistically is one of hundreds
of other issues that they probably ran into and it just happens
to line up with also what happened recently. Next one up this
one comes along with a clip to show you guys but they're chatting
back and forth and somebody sent any Twitch link here from one
of Pirate Software's streams and I'll play the clip here. I wanted
to ask are the mods okay?
Did you maybe lose the basement key? Notice they're less around.
Just wanted to know. I don't mind if you won't explain. Was just
wondering if everything is okay. Happy to be a part of this place.
Keep on keeping up. Chat remember to use bread and watch the
Do you think I should pour some like noodles down there like
like is there
is there like a food that I'm am I supposed to feed them? Now
that you've got that context they follow up here saying yep plus
did try to make it a joke so we can dodge it in a funny way.
Am I supposed to feed them? Dot dot dot. He at this point had
lost pretty much most of his mod team if not all of them. Probably
did the thing to Chronos I think that's what led to all of the
other mods also kind of dipping. And yeah they weren't super
stoked about it. Following it up just seems like these people
really prefer Chronos over Pirate Software at this point. Someone
is I'm assuming messaging someone earlier. Chronos is not Pirate
Software mod. Another individual says Chronos I'm sorry you have
a community of people that prefer hanging out with you rather
than Thor cuz you have a much chiller cooler place with less
drama that could have easily been avoided or reduced. So like
as much as it is just a good point it's like okay
Dude, this is actually like a yeah like a mutiny kind of. Yeah,
yeah. Is Chronos
That feels that feels pretty brutal. drama over here this community
it's interesting that they're making a point that there could
have been less drama that was easily avoided or reduced referencing
that Pirate did not handle it well. And then somebody else down
here former mod he has nobody to blame but himself. He sees enemies
and then makes them his enemies. Sounds like you know describing
how he was turning on like his mod team like Chronos.
Well, Chronos is supposed to become the new Mischa. Dude, I don't
know if Chronos streams. I
Like that could be the start of a streaming career but I feel
like Chronos is Chronos doesn't seem like the kind of guy who
could be a good streamer or like a big streamer anywhere near
like Pirate Software. Some element of becoming a good streamer
is just being like a totally malignant narcissist.
Like if you're willing to just take everything from everybody
that is what builds up like a big stream unironically. Like that
is the best way to become a big streamer is to like be funny
be dynamic but also to be like a narcissist who will take everything
from everybody all the time. And I I just can't see Chronos that
way cuz it seems like he did so much work for very little benefit
for Pirate Software. He doesn't seem like he's got the
I just I yeah I don't know I don't know if he can make it work.
>> as an enemy makes him an enemy even if that wasn't the
case. Following up though we have something where it seems like
they're chatting about a situation or Chronos is talking about
something that happened to him and the other people are chatting
saying when did that happen? Oh god just always shift on mood
is never fun to deal with. Doing something based on somebody's
mood that day that must have sucked. I'm sorry you went through
that. That's not okay. Yeah right he has no empathy. Again assuming
that they're talking about Pirate Software. And then the last
screenshot that I have to show you guys are them chatting more
so starting with quote unquote friend. This is the same person
chatting in these two that I'm going to read back to back. They
say well it used to be better than corporate referring to their
job working under Pirate Software. And then they said that work
environment didn't last very long. And then to jump back before
that someone else had said friends so long as you're super convenient.
Person talking about how the work environment has changed says
Jesus Christ man I know right. Followed up with that was my problem
with everything. He did very little to see things from any other
perspective. Now where have we heard that before? It is to some
degree cathartic to see that It's the Dr. K interview. It's the
Dr. It's the Dr. K interview. Dude, the Dr. K interview is so
funny.
Man, if you guys didn't watch that content, the Dr. K interview
with Pirate Software is so good. Dr. K is like explaining It's
like watching someone
Man, how can I explain it? Imagine you had a colorblind test,
but it was for being a good person.
the person who's like doing the test is
like getting angry at the interviewer at at the person conducting
the test for saying they're wrong even though they think they're
right. I don't know. It's so wild. Like Dr. K perfectly lays
out what's wrong with Pirate Software and why it's a problem.
And
they go to into like meta discussions that all are basically
the core flaw that Dr. K points out that you can assume other
people's positions. You never understand how anybody reacts to
the way the things you say or how you act. You can't understand
it.
>> And so you need to like at least use context clues when
you make a big mistake to sort of go back and try to fix it.
Even if you can't understand it, you got to go back and try to
fix it or do something. And then Pirate Software would basically
go, "Yeah, I just I I don't know if I see it that way, man."
It's like [laughter] No, IT'S NOT ABOUT HOW YOU SEE IT. IT'S
ABOUT HOW EVERYONE ELSE SEES IT. Come on, man. What are you doing?
>> The mod team was having the same issues and now it kind
of recontextualizes it that like yeah, maybe Yeah, that's like
that's like your opinion and I I think you just don't really
know what I'm doing over here and like I I maybe but I No, I
don't think so. No, I don't think so. They weren't the biggest
fans of the guy, but they were getting paid. Like they were part
of that community for however long when it was good. So I don't
necessarily blame them for noticing these things, being bothered
by them, but still sticking around. It's like when you're doing
it for a job and the boss is kind of an ass, you just kind of
put up with it. And then down here continuing, someone said same
here and following after that. And it was always this is what
I did and why I did it. That's why it's fine. Which I'm pretty
sure is exactly what he explained to Dr. K and how Dr. K responded
to that with being Yeah, that makes you sound incredibly incredibly
arrogant. I think sometimes the things that I talk about in regards
to those types of things is misconstrued as arrogance or boasting.
When in reality, I'm just trying to give context.
So that is the problem right there. So I want you to listen to
this phrase.
Sure. This gets misconstrued in is arrogance, but in reality,
it's this. That is
You don't see reality. I see reality. I know what's actually
happening and you are emotional and not able to see the issue
clearly. So I I basically explain to you what reality is and
then you deny it because you are psychotic. You are losing your
mind. It's the most arrogant statement on the planet, bro.
Like tell me I'm wrong. Okay.
I don't see it that way, but all right. Now as it comes to a
close, just Dude, I just literally I don't see it that way. He
literally That dude, I'm pretty sure they got the moment perfectly
that I just described. I'm pretty Dude, I thought I didn't think
I got it nearly verbatim, but it actually is nearly verbatim.
That's the That's what he said.
It's crazy. >> thing to show you guys as I am a man of
my word, here are the photos from me trying to reach out to some
of the mods to see if they were willing to have a comment on
it. The most I got out of it was they don't wish to comment.
Also, make better content. So I'm going to try to make the the
jump cuts feel a bit more natural with this one out of respect
for making a bit more quality content for you guys. And same
thing with this bad boy, I you know, gave a bit of information
here. No thanks. You know, you could just leave it alone, right?
Of all the content to create, you chose this one. This guy is
like kind of the primary Pirate Software farmer. Like to the
point, like I said earlier, that he has actual anti-Pirate Software
merch about doubling down. Okay? And then he's messaging the
mod team after like they're basically all leaving because this
guy destroyed the place they like to hang out. Is sort of how
they they probably see it. And now he's messaging them be like,
"Hey, do you guys want to talk about how that place got destroyed?
You want to talk about what's going on?" Now look, were they
kind of being stinky to me? Yeah. But from their point of view,
I for sure deserve it. And I'm sure that they wanted to be a
A OH MY GOD!
IS HE Is he casually styling on Pirate Software right now going
like, "Watch. Watch me assume somebody else's point of view.
Well, from their point of view, I might actually deserve to be
treated like shit." And if only Pirate Software could have done
that, maybe he wouldn't have lost 18,000 concurrent >> bit
more nasty to me than they even were. So kudos to them for being
as respectful in in their in their disses as they were. The end
of the day, they've been dealing with this drama and this drama
has led to them kind of leaving. I don't know how good they had
it with Pirate Software during the glory days of of working with
him, but I can't Get that many viewers? He did, Argentical. He
did. He had
Oh man, what was his all-time peak? We'll go back to what? 2020?
Right here should be good. Okay, his all-time peak viewership.
Okay, I I'm positive that he was streaming it on YouTube at this
time as His all-time peaks are around 10, 15,000.
But dude, maybe I Did I not go back far enough? No, I did. I
could have sworn he had way bigger streams. I could have sworn
during some of the wild stuff that he was chilling at like 20K.
I'm not even joking. So he was getting up close to 20,000.
Down to two. This was around the time the hardcore wild stuff.
Right when he started picking up the hardcore wild stuff, he
was the big dog.
And he blew it all up. You hate to see it. >> imagine that
they would be very kind to anybody, including myself or anyone
else that has made videos covering the Pirate Software drama.
I I doubt that they would be happy to be speaking with any of
us. I know that I've done my best to be charitable when there
is room to be charitable with Pirate or with any of the other
content that I covered. That's kind of my whole goal is to try
to
unbiased or when I do have an inclination to let you guys know
and let you make your own decisions. But I do want to make it
clear in this situation with these mods, don't go after them.
Don't don't, you know, call them because they're they're being
mean to me. I really don't blame them. There's a good chance
that all these people are swell people. I don't necessarily doubt
when they were saying things like, "Hey, you know, you guys the
reason that mods and other streamers didn't immediately [__]
that just said swell.
Okay, I feel like we've got the core of the drama. I really only
needed the Pirate Software clip, we could have ended it right
there. But hey, thank you, Quintio, for the short little Pirate
Software
reminder, the the walk down nostalgia alley. Thank you so much.
What a video.